on afrique toujours la banque africaine
de développement s'inquiètent de la
situation en tunisie en cause un taux
d'endettement à la hausse et une crise
politique qui n'en finit pas le point
avec basséenne chibli à tunis
la tunisie serait-elle au bord de la
banqueroute c'est en tout cas est la
crainte de la banque africaine de
développement la bad qui n'a pas hésité
à réitérer ses mises en garde dans son
rapport présenté dans le cadre d'un
webinaire sur la situation économique
des pays africains avec une dette
extérieure atteignant les 90 7,2 pour
cent en 2020 la tunisie présente le taux
le plus élevé d'afrique du nord au coeur
des préoccupations de la bad le scénario
d'une aide publique pouvant s'envoler à
près de 100% du pib national c'est la
tunisie n'engage pas rapidement elle les
réformes nécessaires à la mi 2020 les
entreprises publiques ont bénéficié de
garanties publiques estimé à 15% du pib
si l'on ajoute la dette des entreprises
d'état à celle de l'administration
centrale la dette publique totale
dépassera nettement 100 % du pib en 2020
alors que les besoins de financement
public était estimé à près de 18 % du
pib la dette publique elle n'a fait
qu'augmenter atteignant les 80 % du pib
poursuivant une tendance à la hausse
depuis 2011 conséquence une dette dont
le coût des intérêts dévore presque 28 %
du budget de l'état limitant ainsi
d'autres dépenses nécessaires au
développement tels que les
infrastructures ou encore à la santé
face à une crise financière sans
précédent accentuée par une instabilité
politique
tunis multiplie les négociations en vue
d'acquérir de nouveaux prêts en avril
2000 celle le fonds monétaire
international avaient répondu
favorablement la tunisie avec l'octroi
d'un prêt de 2 8 milliards de dollars
sur quatre ans à condition que tunis
amorce un certain nombre de réformes
structurelles comme la réduction des
dépenses publiques ou l'aide au secteur
privé face à l'inaction des autorités
tunisiennes ne répondant pas aux
doléances du fmi le pays n'avait reçu
que 1,6 milliard de dollars au bord de
la faillite et tunis a annoncé de
nouvelles négociations avec
l'institution financière objectif
décrocher un nouveau prêt d'une valeur
de 4 milliards de dollars de quoi
respirer un petit peu au contraire
s'enfoncer davantage dans le
surendettement